faço um desafio com o drone
como vocês podem ver este drone já tem
muito gasto já tudo o partido a que aqui
está partido que já ficou quente esse
tempo já não fecha e faz com que os
produtos também portanto eu não vou
costuro possuído
eu não sei o que se passa aqui e como
vocês podem ver outra vez
como vocês podem ver isso aqui tá tudo
fugido já mas eu vou tentar falar com
ela indaga e ver no que dá e ou a deus
só vão ter agora que cola que a gente
não sair e vou aqui no inter também
porque essa parte há toda a partida a
equipe de salva vidas
chega
vejam só não funciona mas ela já não
andava a churrasco
além disso não precisa ou o próprio deus
o
sua luta desafio do milan diga oi porque
acabou de ser um motor pessoal
ok agora acreditar que isso funciona
então o pessoal todo está neste desafio
muito louco não é
enquanto ela quer se eu vou te ensinar
atirar num café arábica primeira
evidência em um café
assim foi um pouquinho em pouquinho
assim depois vamos colocar não açúcar
porque açúcar embora vamos colocar sim
esteja muito gostoso tomando é só
preciso uma mulher foi um título olha aí
para só bastante agradável com o açúcar
com todo este café batizar uma
vitalidade e norma a vossa alma agora
para é só colocar água
isto é o café é só mexer um pouquinho
para de um estudo nisto tamanho 1 a 1
vamos colocar o motor
uma conseguiu nesta final e não funciona
assim
ae carvalho lei fun
ae
ei ae
o que sabe
a lei agora ficamos sem câmera -
portanto subiu sozinho
[ __ ]
foi só mais o cara tá tendo assim um
parafuso pessoal vou tentar agora fazer
uma coisa que eu vou tentar ajudar o
túnel perdeu assim o cvv da criação deus
mas acredita fechou imaginando o que
levou saleh a casa planeta
a futura animais twitter
aí o assunto ele fura o terreno não é
isso
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar porque
construiu bom eu tentei ao máximo fazer
qualquer coisa que com as drogas mas eu
já não funciona para mim só o cofre tv e
é isso fique bem
espero que tenham gostado de astro boy a
próxima está não funciona